なんで日本に来た not 外国人をよく聞かれる
僕の場合その理由は各峠にある幼い頃にニンジャタートルズを通してからてを知りそこ
から日本っていう国に興味を持つようになった
しかし日本に行ってみたいなあと思わせてくれたのは日本の音楽だ
ソフトボールのはらはでそして椎名林檎もし
住居に魅了されたとき一度でいいから日本に行ってみたいと僕は思った
それで日本語を独学し始めとするとまた予想会のことが起こった漢字を勉強していく
うちにその文字自体が好きになりいつのまにか
日本に行ってみたいっていう気持ちは将来日本に住んでみたいに変化していたと言う
のが後から自分を納得させていた理由だが日本に行きたいと思っていた本当の理由は
アニメにあった
日本に来いよと誘ってくれていたのはもちろんいうつみたいな変に複雑な感じじゃなく
て
孫悟空とベジータだったのだっていうのも実は半分そうだ
本当の動機は日本のゲイ
6だった確かに僕は学校のノートに自分の名前をカタカナで書いてみたり
金曜日の夜に友達と一緒に元団6の見たりしてはいたら日本に対する情熱の源泉は
ファイナルファンタジー7っていうゲームにあったのが独創的な登場人物たち
その想いを引き立てるし繊細な音楽何度も何度も攻略本開きたくなるその面白くて複雑
な物語
メニューの交換をにさえ心を奪われ僕はとうとう日本のゲームソフト会社に勤めると
いう夢を持つようになった
お分かりのように僕がそこまで日本に夢中になれたのは日本の子
と表面的にしか理解していなかったからこそだベスト金と
攻殻機動隊そしてユフィキサラギしか知らなかっぱ僕には日本が完璧な国に見えた
自分のことを知っている人間が誰もいないその完璧な日本に行って理想の人生送ろうと
僕は思っていた多くの外国人と同じ
ように日本に行きたいっていう気持ちの根源には生まれ変わりたい
ありのままの自分を出してそれを煽りの人に理解してもらいたいという欲求にあったの
は
と人生を途中で諦めてしまった英会話教師がよく言うけれどこれも僕が日本に来た本当
の理由ではないと思う
正直なところ僕には自分が日本に来た理由はもうよくわからない
日本に来る前からそれは5回ぐらい変わっているし
日本に来た後も日本で結婚したと思う
日本で子供をつくった後も喉関わっている
分かっているのは日本に行かなきゃ切実におも人間がいるって言うことだ
日本は完璧な国ではないそれどころか彼の国に比べてはるかに遅れているメモへ
それでもどうしても日本に
かなければならない日本にいなければならないと思う人間がいるテレビ番組ではその
理由としてさっき言ったような
例えば格闘技や音楽アニメやゲームなどがよく引き合いに出されるが最近僕は動機
なんて具体的に特定したり客観的に説明したりできるものではないと思うよ
僕たちが日本のどこに惹かれたかというと
パラてと g pop とか flcl とファイナルファンタジーなどというより
むしろその数々の奇跡生み出した何かもなどと思う
その日本ならでものものを味わいそれを通して自分の人生を豊かにしたくてパックさん
の人が内に位置しているのだと
僕はもう一言でいえば僕たちは自分がどうして日本にかなければならないのかわから
ない
しかしかなければならないことだけはわかっているだからなんで日本に来たのと聞かれ
たな
僕は最近こう答えている
分からない分からないけど来てよかったよ